hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the ways
that William James tries to explain to
his audience in pragmatism lecture to
what pragmatism is is by framing it in
relation to two broad movements or
approaches of philosophy that they're
going to be very conversant with and
which we typically talk about in history
philosophy or intro to philosophy
classes but don't use as terms quite so
often today and these are the
rationalist side on one part and then
the empiricist side on another and you
know typically we teach this in relation
to the British empiricist and the
Continental rationalist we like to line
them up in threes because that's very
convenient so we talk about Locke
Berkeley Hume as empiricists and we talk
usually at least in english-speaking
settings about Descartes Spinoza
Leibnitz and we ignore everybody else
who fits into those those spectra like
for example on the rationalist side we
should probably also pay attention to
Nicolas Ma brush and too you know Arno
and some of these other important
thinkers and on the empiricist side
which
probably think about you know read and
and common-sense philosophy and all
sorts of other things that we can say as
well and the other thing I'll point out
too is that there are rationalist
tendencies within Locke pretty strongly
and it's not as if the Continental
thinkers never looked at experience so
these are kind of you know there's a
spectrum here now there there was an
important set of you could say dividing
dividing issues dividing lines that
allowed us to make this distinction it
was not merely the English channel that
was doing so and you could say that the
the fundamental differences had to do in
their approaches towards reasoning how
it was used its importance and
discovering truth and in the origins of
knowledge how much of our knowledge
comes from experience or reflection upon
experience and experience it has to be
understood in a broad sense to not only
include you know sense perception but
also perception of our sentiments or
passions and the operations of our minds
is very clear and Locke and Hume and
Berkeley right and you know is there
anything else that's going on or are we
essentially blank slates and then we we
get this information coming in and an
essential human nature processes it or
do we already have some of our knowledge
at least in some perhaps undeveloped or
unconscious way available to us in what
Rene Descartes called the treasure house
the thesaurus is the Latin for it of the
the mind just waiting for the natural
light to illuminate certain truths and
so this is one of the things that
divided the rationalist from the
empiricists it's very silly to say that
the rationalist were entirely devoted to
AA priori reasoning you know that had
nothing to do with the world that that's
a caricature and just you know complete
nonsense when we look at the text but
they're you know Descartes thanks for
example the very idea of true
is not something that we're gleaning
from our experience it's something we're
bringing to our experience and then if
we go further in history beyond the 16th
and 17th century and we in an 18th
century as well and we start looking at
the 19th century you know there's
there's rationalistic and empiricist
tendencies within the vast movements of
philosophy that James would have himself
been very conversant with for example
idealism which he doesn't you know fix
the the the you know predicate of German
to but it is very much drawing upon
German idealism from Conte onward right
and we can also talk about positivism
and other other movements that are going
on as being more rationalistic or being
more empiricist so James has all of
these things in mind when he's trying to
say where pragmatism is going to fit in
with respect to these two different
tendencies and he tells us early on in
the lecture pragmatism represents a
perfectly familiar attitude and
philosophy the empiricist attitude but
it represents it as it seems to me both
in a more radical and in a less
objectionable form that it has ever
assumed so this is you know quite
important he's saying you know we're on
Team empiricist but were not partisans
of the empiricists because the
traditional empiricists now there's some
problems with them as well but we're
definitely not on the rationalistic side
and I'll tell you why in just a moment
he goes on and he says pragmatist turns
his back resolutely and once for all
upon a lot of inveterate habits dear to
professional philosophers he turns away
from abstraction and insufficiency from
verbal solutions from bad operatory
reasons from fixed principles closed
systems and pretended absolutes and
origins he turns towards concreteness
and adequacy towards facts towards
action and towards power now he
summarizes this by saying
that means the empiricist temper regnant
and the rationalists temper sincerely
given up
it means the open air and possibilities
of nature as against dogma artificiality
and the pretense of finality and truth
but this is actually a passage worth
pausing and reflecting on a bit is all
rationalism being thereby dismissed
notice what he's saying here turning
away from abstraction okay that is
turning away from rationalism and
insufficiency you know things that can't
actually satisfy us verbal solutions
another thing he'll he'll target the
rationalist for but empiricists often
fall into that as well
bad priori reasons he's not criticising
opry reasons period he's saying bad ones
you know we might think for example
about the reasoning in Candide about why
we have noses right if you're not
familiar with Voltaire is book I forget
whether it's noses or ears but they're
so we can hang our spectacle on now
that's garbage reasoning and that's what
a bad rationalist would be doing but
that's not necessarily all rationalism
from fixed principles okay you know that
can be rational ii also be empiricists
if they go a certain way and closed
systems and pretended absolutes and
origins so notice that he's saying some
of these things really can't support the
weight that we would put on them and
that's the problem with the rationalist
approach so he talks about a few other
things concerned with with rationalism
he spends a lot more time criticizing
that than empiricism in this piece what
other problems is a commitment to what
we can call a static version of truth
and and James wants to offer us a
different conception of truth one that's
he calls it a genetic theory of truth
one that shows truth able to grow able
to develop over time and here's a good
example of what he's criticizing truth
independent
truth that we find merely truth no
longer malleable to human need truth
incorrigible he says that this is the
kind of truth that rationalistic the
minded thinkers are after and he likens
this to the deadwood within a living
tree it serves some purpose but it's not
something good in and of itself and so
it's again rather static a little bit
later on he tells us that the way in
which rationalist view truth it's by the
way something that's corresponding to
their criticism of the pragmatic
attitude I'll just read this passage
here he says that miss you know Schiller
has been criticized for being pragmatic
by that rationalistic temper and he says
pragmatism is uncomfortable away from
facts rationalism is comfortable only in
the presence of abstractions the the
pragmatist talk about truths and the
plural their utility and
satisfactoriness about the success with
which they work suggests to the typical
intellectualist mind a sort of coarse
lame second-rate makeshift article of
truth such truths are not the real truth
such tests are merely subjective so you
see where this is going they you know
the rationalist are willing to say well
you can have your little truths over
there whatever you want to call truths
but they're not really truth with a
capital T and he goes on he says as
against this objective truth must be
something non-utilitarian haughty
refined remote august exalted now notice
the next sentence
it must be an absolute correspondence of
our thoughts with an equally absolute
reality so this is a very hardcore
correspondence theory of truth which
assumes that there is an absolute truth
out there and that absolute truth is
something static eternal defined once
and for all and it's our job to align
ourselves with that by whatever means
we're going to use most likely those
those things of the intellect sense
nothing sensual or change
is going to be able to handle that and
again we've got you know static
conception he also calls this being
intellectualist as well and so there's
you know a strong criticism of what the
pragmatists are doing and a very
different conception of truth on the
part of the rationalist James criticizes
them for several other things he calls
them intellectual istic and that means
that you know I'll go on with this
passage because this will be a great
example it truth must be what we ought
to think unconditionally the conditioned
ways in which we do think are so much
irrelevance and matter for psychology
down with psychology up with logic now
if you ever heard of psychology ISM
outside of the realm of you know these
discussions rationalism empiricism maybe
in the realm of phenomenology and or you
know other other 20th century movements
that's what James is talking about there
he would say that their intellectual
astir rationalistic right we need to
actually look at things how they are not
just reason our way to them and he tells
us that the the rationalist loves to
stick to logic to what they can deduce
and to the Empyrean now this is a fancy
term for you know what's in the heavens
what is above us could be the Platonic
forms could be you know the konchem
categories and you know forms of
intuition and the ideas the ideas rather
than ideals you know all of this sort of
stuff or it could be whatever we want it
to be but it's going to be something
that is way above us in which we can
form ourselves - he also tells us
another thing that is kind of you know
interesting here he says that the
typical ultra abstractionist shudders at
concreteness all the other things being
equal he positively prefers the pale and
spectral if the two universe or you know
versus were offered he would always
choose the skinny outline rather than
the rich
thicket of reality why it is so much
purer clearer nobler now when we hear
that we can we can really see that you
don't actually have to be a continental
rationalist and you could actually be in
many respects devoted to empiricism but
of a certain sort and still embrace that
that hyper intellectualism that James is
criticizing and saying that pragmatism
is a good response too you just have to
have an impoverished reality you might
think about you know somebody like GK
Chesterton in orthodoxy who talks about
the madman as having a very clean
concise reality that's unfortunately too
small right so rationalism is you know
going to be rejected here what about
empiricism are the the pragmatists
simply empiricists are they hyper
empiricists that's what James suggested
earlier right there more radical
empiricism what does that actually mean
it means that think about what
empiricism is about that they're going
to go to experience that they're gonna
make experience absolutely central in
their understanding of inquiry and
reasoning and where we derive knowledge
from are the empiricists empiricist
enough the answer is No many of them
have a devotion to dogma just as strong
as a rationalist does it's just a
different kind of dogma and so James
says pragmatism devoted as it is to
facts has no such materialistic bias as
ordinary empiricism Labor's under all
right so if there are things that you
know we are trying to understand we
don't have to adopt a reductive
materialism towards them just because
the scientists you know may be like that
are actually not even really the
scientists usually caring about that
it's usually the philosophers it's
usually the people who are devoted to a
reductionist program a naturalism
that has to be you know kind of let's
say too narrow right a genuine
naturalism would take in all the
experiences that we have we see James
talking about this in in other places
like the will to believe and the variety
of the varieties of religious experience
he also criticizes the the empiricists
for just like the rationalist sticking
to something he says empiricism sticks
to the external senses so if we want to
think about what pragmatism is committed
to that takes it beyond ordinary
ordinary empiricism and also rationalism
he tells us pragmatism is willing to
take anything to follow either logic or
the senses and to count the humblest and
most personal experiences she will even
count mystical experiences if they have
practical consequences she will take a
God who lives in the very dirt of
private fact if that should seem a
likely place for him so pragmatism
represents a radical empiricism as James
was very willing to call it and it's
pluralistic it doesn't try to impose one
schema upon everything as the way to
explain at all so what we see here is
that that pragmatism is definitely on
one side but it's not on that one side
in a narrow partisan dogmatic fashion
you